vamos a practicar un poco con las
propiedades de los exponentes en
especial cuando tenemos exponentes
enteros veamos a que es igual 4 a la
menos 3 x 4 a la quinta y como siempre
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y
piensen cómo resolverían esto por su
cuenta
hay un par de formas en las que podemos
resolver esto una es darnos cuenta de
que estamos multiplicando algo que tiene
la misma base por lo que el resultado
tendrá esta misma base 4 y luego sumó
los exponentes menos tres más 5 que es
lo mismo que tener 4 a la segunda
potencia y aquí estamos aplicando
directamente una propiedad de los
exponentes pero también podemos pensar
porque es que esto tiene sentido 4 a la
menos 3 es lo mismo que tener 1 entre 4
a la 3 o lo que es lo mismo 1 entre 4
por 4 x 4 y 4 a las 5 es lo mismo que
tener 54 es multiplicados en tres y
cuatro por cuatro por cuatro por cuatro
por cuatro y noten que cuando hacemos
esta multiplicación vamos a tener 54 en
el numerador y 34 en el denominador por
lo que tres de estos se van a cancelar
por lo que nos vamos a quedar solamente
con dos cuatros que se multiplican entre
sí y este 4x4 es lo mismo que tener
cuatro al cuadrado ahora hagamos otro
ejercicio con variables digamos que
tenemos a la menos 4 x a cuadrada a que
será igual esto nuevamente tenemos la
misma base que en este caso es a por lo
que al multiplicar las simplemente vamos
a sumar los exponentes nos queda ha
elevado a menos cuatro más dos lo que es
igual a ha elevado a la potencia menos
dos y nuevamente aquí aplicamos
directamente una propiedad de los
exponentes pero porque tiene sentido
bueno esto de acá es 1 / a
por a
y esto es por a por a así que este es el
cancela con este y este otro también se
cancela con este de acá y nos queda uno
entre a por a que es lo mismo que tener
ha elevado a la potencia menos 2 ahora
hagamos otro ejercicio pero con un
cociente y ahora les pregunto a que va a
ser igual 12 elevado a la potencia menos
7 entre 12 elevado a la potencia menos 5
si tenemos un cociente con la misma base
simplemente vamos a restar los
exponentes así que en este caso nos
queda que es 12 elevado a menos 7 -
menos 5 estamos restando el exponente de
abajo nos va a quedar que 12 está
elevado a
al restar un negativo es lo mismo que si
sumáramos un positivo así que nos queda
menos 75 es igual a menos 2 y nuevamente
vamos a pensar porque esto tiene sentido
el 12 a la menos 7 entre 12 a la menos 5
lo podemos reescribir como 12 a la menos
7 por 12 a la quinta porque estamos
tomando el recíproco de lo que se
encuentra aquí abajo debido a que tiene
un exponente negativo al tomar el
recíproco nos queda el exponente
positivo y nos queda algo como lo que
vimos en los primeros ejemplos ahora
finalmente hagamos otro ejercicio de
estos pero usando variables ahora
tenemos x elevado a la potencia menos 20
entre x elevado a la quinta y nuevamente
tenemos la misma base y como éste es un
cociente nos va a quedar que esto es
igual a x elevado a menos 20 menos 5 ya
que tenemos a este en el denominador así
que esto es igual a x elevado a la
potencia
-25 nuevamente podemos ver nuestra
expresión original como x a la menos 20
x el recíproco del denominador que es x
a la menos 5 y en este caso simplemente
sumamos los exponentes lo que nos da
nuevamente x elevado a la potencia menos